sup guys Greg Galois finally made it to
the last episode of the defenders I'm
gonna do a serious review with Andrew
from the movie source channel I'll get
my quick thoughts in the final episode
after it's done but yeah I just want to
watch this
Jessica this is really starting to feel
like a 90s
look she pulled that light off really
well
[Laughter]
guitars am
oh is that five from the trailer
[Music]
boom-shaka-laka
[Music]
and the hands subnet fighting disguise
[Music]
and I'm so sick of watching these two
so repetitive
there's no damage that you can do to me
that can't be undone especially is the
iron fist assertive even stable to a
gift like that man I'll give you one
last chance to be human to be
[Music]
the hand is foolish shitty fighters
[Music]
go back to light
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
daughters of the Dragon there it is Oh
boom
money shot baby here is a tracking shot
[Music]
hello casual luke cage's
nice
[Music]
[Music]
once they get believe one Alexandre she
know
[Music]
yeah we can we have to we got a plan
[Music]
they do not know how to whisper very
well
[Music]
Hulk smash
[Music]
oh that's a cool moment okay all right
you go forward the rap music
[Music]
oh good seriously Kix daredevil this guy
season quit
he sucks
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
cackling Terminator 2
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
damn Danny just keep getting your ass
handed to
now the air fish she goes away put him
down in the head why don't you just kill
her else would you expect the Kudo
[Music]
that's why I saved you come raise you
because that seems
[Music]
oh no oh god damn I'm gonna be doing a
serious review about get my quick
thoughts in the episode there were
definitely stuff to like there's stuff I
definitely didn't really like in this
episode after it's all said and done I
guess my general consensus on this is
that this show is it's it's it's okay
it's better than good it's not great
always kind of a letdown I mean I felt a
combo of two things overall with this
series and I feel like the last two
episodes really contribute to this at
times it really feels like this show was
being rushed cuz they only have eight
episodes and then there were also times
where felt like the writers don't really
care as much about this series as they
do about their the solo shows which is
why the first few episodes felt a little
stretched and then the last couple felt
rushed I mean there's some scenes I'd
like to hear one of the highlight scenes
for me was the scene when Karen and
Trish are interacting with each other I
think it's a rewarding scene for fans of
the show with Karen being a victimized
character just to a character of
strength very similar to Trish's
experience in Jessica Jones show while
Trish has a radio show talking about
events that are happening in New York
you know Karen is a journalist talking
about events that are happening in New
York and they're both very close to the
main heroes of the show's they star in
it was really cool seeing I thought the
actresses did a really good job is kind
of a quiet subtle scene but I thought
they did a really good job working
together he's cool you seen the redhead
and the blonde talk with each other I
mean the big fight at the end had its
moments like the the big tracking shot
they you know the Avengers money shot
that it was a cool shot but I thought
what they were doing wasn't that cool
what they're trying to do like make this
feel like The Avengers which is one of
my issues with what I felt with this
episode but the tracking shots similar
to how they
the Avengers with the trash on the
Avengers was sweet and what they were
cutting to all the something we're doing
was really cool here what everything
they were showing that they were doing
in the tracking shot was like the end
it's all right I mean when to switch
into rap music I thought the fight
actually got better overall the finale
epic moments I felt very corn if a very
cheesy man I think I said it at one
point it's sort of felt like I was
watching a 90s movie the last two
episodes as a whole just sort of felt
that way to me the tone was just super
off like the tone of these characters
solo shows are much more serious more
gritty more raw very violent and then
the last two episodes kind of wanted a
generic conventional cheesy superhero
territory for me
and I feel like overall they couldn't
really balance the tone and style of
what we loved so much from these solo
shows trying to also give us fanservice
by trying to be all super heroic like
defenders assemble you know even this
episodes call the defenders and they're
shooting the scenes underground like it
is supposed to be that but I'm not
really feeling that and the fight just
really solidified my opinion that the
hand just sucks they don't seem
threatening at all they just the most
part like I don't know if all these
people are part of the hands
specifically or if they're just henchmen
but it just felt like they were taking
out a bunch of henchmen I mean
Daredevils moments were still very cool
I just feel like for the big finale
fight there you've been building up so
much for the New York's about to crumble
and if you're not gonna give us New
York's about to crumble in you're gonna
give us this fight
give us a fight with a bunch of skilled
warriors it's not a bunch of henchmen
and I said this in the last episode it
really just doesn't feel like Luke Cage
and daredevil could have handled us all
on their own it just feels like Jessica
Jones and iron fist just sped up the
process but I didn't feel by the end of
it all that all four were super
essential it's really just the tone that
missed the main mark for me and launched
them it's a corny territory
I mean Makuta a calling wing fighting
each other I didn't find necessary I
didn't need it for the defenders it felt
very repetitive from iron fist I felt
like they had that scene to set up misty
night you know with getting your arm cut
off his eye I remember seeing an image
where she had a robotic arm and I think
in the comment I read this a long time
ago I did not know this is gonna happen
in the show but I remember a long time
ago that like her arm gets cut off
higher man actually who gives her Tony
Stark he's supposed to give her the
bionic arm but base not how they're
setting it up in the show that they had
their own billionaire playboy you know
Finn Jones that he's probably gonna
somehow help provide that but it serves
a bakudo and Colleen wait you just felt
like the same repetitive [ __ ] but I mean
I like the setup for misty night I
appreciated that
I mean iron fist taking up the mantle to
be the hero of New York from being
inspired by Matt Murdock it felt forced
to me I didn't really find their
specific relationship the dynamics they
form in this series to be so important
and highly valuable to iron fists it's
like I know they respect each other and
appreciate each other but not to that
degree it felt like they were forcing in
a comic book plot point that I I'm
vaguely familiar with of iron fist
sometimes pretending to be daredevil to
help conceal Matt's identity I feel like
they're trying to push that in there and
I are faced I think that's the green
suit like the jumpsuit had an electric
going at it I felt could have been
handled better to Elektra like she's
doing a good job with the performance
but the writing of it man is just so
generic to me and I'm also not a big fan
of when shows or movies try to play out
how a character dies or BVS with
Superman or even here they don't play it
out as long but you know with daredevil
dying it's like I know they're trying to
show this is how it's affecting the
characters and I get that but I'm like
you don't really try to fool the
audience I mean one thing I could tell
you is that this this season finale got
me excited for the other character solo
shows I mean other than Luke Cage it
didn't really have a character art or a
wrap up on Luke Cage in some ways the
ending of this is disappointing because
it had all these personal set ups that
the first two episodes really took their
time to establish you know I wish we had
a scene where Jessica Jones I'm glad
she's going back to work so we could
continue her show where she opens up
alias what about that whole relationship
with the wife and daughter like we
should
I felt like we should have had some type
of conclusion on that and Luke Cage
getting involved cuz that kid from
Harlem got killed and no real rap up
there that was the whole like reasoning
for why he got so personally involved
but I'm glad to see Jessica Jones going
back to work even though I felt a little
forced here I'm setting up iron fists to
become an official vigilante for New
York City is really cool misty Knight
and Colleen Wayne teaming up an iron
fist daughters of the Dragon looking
forward to that and the daredevil ending
note was cool I read an interview with
Charlie Cox before the defenders was
released that season 3 of daredevil
would possibly be inspired by the
born-again storyline from the comics I
remember they talked about like you know
they have a status Jack Murdock and then
reading up on born again then his mom
Maggie is involved so I'm assuming that
when he says get sister Maggie that
that's his mom and just make the most
sense based off what my remember from a
couple months ago which gets me excited
because we haven't seen any of Matt's
mom and any of the daredevil seasons
there was so much emphasis on his father
and father figures I'm excited to see
you know like how his mom plays into his
life and Andrews just showed up we're
gonna shoot our defenders review in a
second see I'm excited for the inclusion
than that in daredevil season 3 what I
would have liked a little bit more from
this show is for the defenders series
that pushed these characters in a little
bit more stronger directions in the end
the hem was very lackluster to me the
impact of the storylines wasn't as
strong of a note to end on as I would
have liked it and the tone kept
flip-flopping a lot for me I feel like
episodes 3 4 5 & 6 right it's best
because still gonna be wrong episodes 1
& 2 at first I felt we're a little dull
but episode 3 made it all worth it for
me oh yeah episode 3 4 5 & 6 I thought
were amazing episode 7 and 8 didn't
really hit the mark overall I would say
this show was good not great I got a
film with Andrew from the movie source
channel the series review of this so
keep a lookout for that I'm sure he has
to be excited here Andrews opinion since
he actually reads the comics and knows
way more than I do so go check out that
video subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell become a
patron objected am i checking out our
patreon please